E aí
e o Que Vocês Fizeram no Verão Passado
é uma pergunta até engraçada não é eu
acho que nós fizemos a mesma coisa a
gente está até de parabéns inclusive
conseguimos sobreviver
isso é uma coisa maravilhosa
nós tivemos uma surpresa diante de um
vírus misterioso
contaminação em massa
vacinas sendo pesquisadas quase na
velocidade da luz
Oi e para que isso para a gente
sobreviver e viver bem e muito ter
longevidade
sei que a velhice ainda é tabu e até
mesmo transtorno para muitas famílias
não para mim fui criada por uma pessoa
que desfrutou
plenamente de sua vida há 11 anos quando
ela faleceu minha avó paterna Dona
Tereza Sim sou cria de vó eu levei o
maior susto e até hoje o espanto por ela
ter falecido tão jovem só 96 anos
ela poderia ter vivido muito mais é uma
pessoa 60 mais deveria conseguir exercer
todas as atividades de vida diária
conhecidas na geriatria pela sigla
avidez sem as limitações de sua idade ou
tempo
a Essas atividades diárias se dividem em
instrumentais Como preparar uma refeição
tomar remédio fazer compra sozinhos e
aquela básica como tomar banho sozinho
alimentar-se vestir-se
controlar continência urinária e fecal
simples tanto então
não precisamos esperar chegar nossa tão
sonhada velhice para simplesmente
bater.
Contamos as horas para chegar à
aposentadoria e até podemos pensar
financeiramente com o vamos passar por
ela mas ninguém ninguém te prepara para
como ir lá passar esse tempo com
autonomia e Independência
física e mental e porquê a fazer
nascemos e a cada minuto vivido ficamos
mais velhos eu não me torno idoso aos 60
anos eu tenho uma trajetória de
envelhecimento Mas será que desde que
somos crianças até idades mais avançadas
tudo precisa se perder ao longo do
caminho
saúde alegria e esperança bem-estar
trocas sociais
e por que não brincar brincar gente mais
velha brinca Sim
todos nós desde que temos trocas com o
mundo externo de pessoas e objetos
e consciência corporal e vamos
construindo uma reserva lúdica
ludicidade em latim todos o que
significa a brincar a brincadeira pode
ser demonstrada através de várias Fontes
os exercícios que trabalham fantasia
imaginação
práticas corporais
dança canto pintura teatro artes em
geral
utilização de elementos da natureza
uso de embalagens objetos recicláveis
sucata a criança faz a troca com o mundo
através da brincadeira e atravessa essa
Troca que ela desenvolve a cognição som
que faz parte da
Autonomia
capacidades psicomotoras e sociais essa
ludicidade ajuda no desenvolvimento das
Tais avidez lembram delas
atividades de vida diária e em é através
do brincar
ludicidade não é coisa só de criança
existe algo dentro de cada um de você aí
que me Assiste como citei antes
chamado reserva lúdica é como se fosse
uma tatuagem são memórias das
brincadeiras
tazar da cultura das crenças que
permitem a cada ser humano trabalhar o
psíquico o equilíbrio corporal e social
frente às temerosos as doenças do
envelhecimento
tenho certeza de que você consegue agora
voltar lá na infância me contar das suas
brincadeiras e te com elas foram
importantes para definir quem você é
hoje quem você fui ontem quem você é
hoje definir você de amanhã Ou seja no
início no tal final da vida seja lá o
que isso signifique
somos eternos aprendizes
mas parece que a humanidade não está
aprendendo direito a cada pessoa
viva com 85 anos ou + temos uma pessoa
na mesma faixa etária com demência é uma
proporção assustadora de um para um e o
que pode ser mais triste do que temos a
velhice resumida a uma sentença de
incapacidade funcional
não precisa ser assim de novo vão temos
ao tema da infância pois no Imaginário
coletivo o brincar é só nessa fase o
lúdico trabalhado com as crianças para
fomentar seu Progresso vendo brincar
seja ele o racional brincar livre
pedagógico por tensões de ensino social
em grupo e terapêutico com auxílio à
cura a reabilitação ou a prevenção de
doenças é um mesmo que precisa ser
aplicado e desenvolvido ao longo da
nossa vida e sobretudo quando nos
tornamos idosos pois tenho certeza de
que não iremos querer apenas existir
queremos viver e é bom se preparar para
essas estatísticas a população
brasileira 60 mais hoje é de sete por
102030 será de 14 meio por cento em 2060
a projeção demográfica é que teremos uma
população de 218 milhões de pessoas nas
quais
58 milhões e são idosos essa projeção do
Instituto Brasileiro de geografia e
estatística o IBGE é de 2013 digo mais
já uma pagamento de que esses números
estão subestimados a expectativa de vida
em 2060 está Projetada para 81,2 anos
por um lado o cenário positivo
maravilhoso mas do ponto de vista de
Saúde Pública
pode ser um enorme problema
segundo o Ministério da Saúde a partir
de 60 mais gasta-se em saúde 25 por
cento a mais do que se cansou a vida
inteira foram gastos em 2010 com
assistência ambulatorial e hospitalar
pelo SUS
25 e meio bilhões de reais considerando
apenas a d Bom dia A projeção para 2030
Edna de 35,8 milhões ou seja um aumento
de
40,4 por cento
infelizmente com a pandemia Imaginem a
subida vertiginosa desses dados uso
muito a projeção de 2030 pois a ONU
estipulou uma agenda de objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentáveis até 2030 os
o desses para construção e implementação
de políticas públicas
guiando a humanidade pela próxima década
de forma que não se esgotem os recursos
naturais
econômicos e sociais de que necessitamos
no presente sem comprometer na geração
futura e entre os 17 o DS dessa lista
temos saúde
só
faltam apenas 9 anos e um ano hoje em
dia como passa rápido
como dizia um antigo mestre que
encontrei nas minhas andanças
à estimulação cognitiva
atividades lúdicas pode ter valor de
remédio e aparecem com uma proposta a
tratamentos não medicamentosos
em equipes multidisciplinares
precisamos de espaço de estimulação
ludicidade e humanização que são as
gerontex as brinquedotecas para 60
milhões a muito urgência muito muito
grande para isso é uma proposta de baixo
custo de capacitação rápida e uma
ferramenta para sim
enfrentarmos a realidade
ou quem sabe e até que possamos que
definir lá vamos aproveitar a velocidade
de cada um de nós dá para fazer tudo
isso e brincando